The leading generals of World War Two,
you carried a huge weight
on their shoulders.
Their decisions could mean the difference
between life and death for thousands
of men and their actions helped
shape the fate of nations.
History has judged some of them as falls.
Others as butches and a handful of
Basil military geniuses view that,
at least on the airline side,
have generated as much
controversy in life and death.
As George S.
Patton,
the flamboyance American commander
never lost a major battle,
but his explosive temper
almost cost him his career.
He survived two world wars,
often placing himself in considerable
danger in lead to die in unlikely
circumstances within
months of Germany's defeat.
The unconventional general
was a devout Christian,
and yet he believed he was just the latest
incarnation of a warrior spirit who'd
once fought alongside the
likes of Julius Caesar,
Napoleon Bonaparte,
and others.
He was the epitome of the rough,
tough warrior who reveled in his macho
image and seemingly lived only for war,
but he could be a surprisingly sensitive
individual who cried at funerals and
even pens,
poetry doing this for most of his life.
In this biographics video.
We're going to dive right into
the details of this man's life.
[inaudible]
Georgia is passive.
Well,
he was born in California on
the 11th 1885 20 years earlier.
The paths and family had lost a bunch of
their wealth when they found themselves
on the losing side of American civil war.
However,
by the time of George's birth,
capacitors were prosperous
and they were influential.
Once again,
the young George Welch,
he knew from an early age that he wanted
to be a soldier is main obstacles to
doing this where his weaknesses
in maths and English,
this wasn't a result
of any lack of ability,
but rather his father's
mistrust of form and education,
which meant that George had to descended
school until he reached 12 years of
age.
He caught up quickly but only narrowly
passed the entrance exam for West Point.
America's most prestigious military
academy while pattern would regularly
clashed with his superiors during World
War Two is conduct at West Point's was
exemplary.
He was particularly successful that
sports such as Polo and football,
playing with some relentless
aggression that he broke several bones.
He would lead to bring this
aggression to his method of waging war
patterns,
considerable sporting ability.
It did not go on notice to do a selected
to represent the United States of
America in the modern pentathlon at the
1912 Stockholm and then big games he
would could be,
is it writing,
shooting,
fencing,
running,
and sweating.
All things that pattern excels at.
Interestingly,
in the event it was patterns
shooting that may let him down.
He fired 20 bullets,
but the judges ruled that three of
them had missed the target pattern,
remained adamant that his aim but actually
been too good and his shots and pass
through the whole he'd
already made and the Bullseye.
It is possible that he was corrected,
but the judge is ultimately
ruled against him.
At the end of the first day pattern was
placed in a slightly disappointing 21st
from a 41 competitors.
Strong performances in each
of the remaining events
that saw him climb all the
way to fifth place.
It was the first and last time
he competed in the Olympic Games,
but he didn't have to wait long to test
the accuracy of his shooting in a combat
situation.
Yeah.
By 1916 most of the world's great
powers were locked together in seemingly
interminable conduct.
Only the United States thus far succeeded
in avoiding being drawn into the
slaughter.
However,
Lyrica did suffer a surprise attack
from the direction of Mexico on Boston.
1916 400 heavily armed bandits led by
notorious Francisco pantry video stormed
across the border for two hours.
They ran Saxons lucid the border town
of Columbus before finally being chased
away by the cavalry.
If Divia believed he could
hide out safely in Mexico,
well,
he was sorely mistaken.
President Woodrow Wilson ordered that the
u s army crossed the border and put an
end to the threat.
John Pershing was given commands of the
Expeditionary Force and he chose pattern
to serve as his eight Pason would go
on to become famous for his skill.
That commanding fast
moving motorized forces,
so it's perhaps fitting
that one in Mexico.
He took part in the first motorized
action in the history of warfare traveling
in three dodge touring cars pattern
and his men launched a raid on videos
henchman.
When the smoke cleared at
the end of a brief firefight,
three of his bodyguards lay debt pass
an audit their bodies to be strapped to
the cars for the drive
back to headquarters.
Pershing,
well,
he was apparently impressed
reportedly saying this pattern boy,
he's a real fighter.
On the 6th of April,
1917 the United States of America declared
war on Germany and entered World War
One.
Pershing was giving commands
if the American expeditionary
force and once again
he took George Patton at his side.
Pershing offered him
an infantry battalion,
but by that time that passenger
had become fascinated by tanks.
They were powerful,
yet unreliable weapons that were still
in their infancy since they'd been
unleashed by the British at the song.
In September of 1916 he became the
first officer assigned to the American
Expeditionary Force tank.
Core ams was at one of the first Americans
to learn how to operate a tank and
it's personally towards the first
cruise to be assigned to the tank corps.
The American Expeditionary Force tank
core finally went into action in September
of 1918 with pattern riding battle or
clinging to the outside of one of them
machines.
Please.
That same month though,
he would be badly injured in an
act of near suicide or bravery,
world war one tanks that they
were seriously underpowered.
They were unreliable and they were totally
vulnerable without infantry support.
So when his tanks,
it became isolated.
During the Meuse Argonne offensive.
Patton calls for volunteers to
help him storm the German lines.
Only five men have stepped forward.
They were quickly cut it down by a hail
of German bullets patterned himself.
He was badly injured
by a piece of shrapnel,
which hits him in the fight.
He continued to direct to
the battle for Michelle.
Hobo anti later refused medical treatment
until he had completed and submitted
his report.
Patton's injuries,
while they weren't life threatening,
they were serious.
So by the time he had recovered
sufficiently to resend it to combat,
well,
the armistice had been signed and
the guns said form and sign it
fall class and his time at the
front lines haven't been brief.
He had done more than enough
to demonstrate that he
possessed the kinds of raw
courage he expected and demanded
of those who served under him.
Okay.
With a great war or is it ends passing
[inaudible] of the United States of
America where he founds a
good deal to keep him busy.
He learns to fly drones.
The latest automobile sales is
a yacht mixed with high society.
He kept a stable of horses
and one hundreds of trophies
and ribbons in numerous
sporting events,
such an extravagant lifestyle would
ordinarily be well out of reach for him.
Majors,
salary.
However,
in 1910 patented married
Beatrice [inaudible] of the
extremely wealthy rs of a
Boston industrialist,
the battens.
Well,
they had enough money to do
pretty much whatever they wanted,
but George never wavered from his belief
that he was destined to be a great
soldier.
He maintained a special interest in
armored warfare and some visionaries.
We're proclaiming the tanks would
become the decisive weapon in any future
conflicts.
Hines Gadarian in Germany and
Charles de Gaulle in France,
I'll give the tanks,
would return mobility to the battlefields
punching through enemy positions to
create havoc in the rear passenger.
He was thinking along similar lines and
he got the chance to test out some of
his ideas.
In 1941 when the U s army held fast war
games across the states of Louisiana and
Carolina,
more than 400,000 soldiers and 1000
Aircrafts took part in mock battles,
held over 30,000 square
miles with Germany.
Once again at war with Britain and Russia.
Ben's no guarantees that America
would be able to remain neutral.
It was a much needed opportunities.
You get to test out
tactics and equipments.
It also served as a test of the men who
would lead America's armies into battle.
The battles they weren't real,
but they were a police,
enough approximation for
61 men to lose their lives.
However,
despite these losses,
the U s army gained valuable experience
and pattern staked his claim.
Do you arguably be the US army's
finest exponents of Ahmed [inaudible].
Oh,
okay.
On the 7th of December,
1941 Japan attacked to the
United States of America.
That's pal harbor.
Four days later,
Germany declared war on America.
As with that World War Two became they
truly global war with plans for a 1942
allies,
invasion of western Europe
having been shelved.
The high command instead
chose to strike it.
Hitler's vishing French
allies in North Africa.
Three separate task forces were launched
with General George Patton at taking
command of 35,000 men of the Western
task force ceiling at the Casablanca from
Virginia.
It pass on that has any fears or doubts?
Well,
he certainly wasn't a showing
them as he wrote in his diary.
When I realize what I am,
I am amazed,
but on reflection,
who is as good as I am,
I know of no one I've ever had.
Lee.
He was fairly modest to the amphibious
landings of the 8th of November when
largely unopposed and despite some
fierce resistance as patterns men pushed
inlands.
The Vichy French signed an
armistice later that day,
far more formidable than the French.
However,
with Germany is a win.
Rommel and his Africa court
on the 14th of February,
1943 they attacked in force striking
a u s troops in years Atlas Mountains.
By the 20th of February,
the immediate crisis it was over,
but the Americans,
they'd been pushed back 50 miles.
Huge amounts of equipment had been
abandoned and 4,000 Americans including
pattern zones.
Son in law had been captured by the
Germans with morale on the floor and those
and how a sac to the commander,
he held responsible and placed all
American troops in Tunisia under patterns,
commands person immediately subjected
as men to an intensive drill routine and
strict disciplinary coat.
His methods weren't far
from university popular,
but they got results and within a month
pattern was on the offensive defeating
the formidable German 10th Panzer Division
at the Battle of El Guitar passing
rapidly build himself a
reputation in north Africa,
but it was here at the t began his
rivalry with Bernard Montgomery,
the commander of the British
Eighth Army while passing.
It was bold,
aggressive,
and often acted on gut instinct.
Montgomery.
It was by nature,
read far more cautious man.
You put great stock in
meticulous planning,
patterned believed Eisenhower
deferred to Montgomery,
far too often a feeling that was only
strengthens when the British commander was
given the go ahead to plan
the invasion of Sicily.
Okay.
The invasion of Sicily was to be a joint
operation conducted the British Eighth
Army led by Montgomery as the u s seventh
on the commanded blink George Pattern,
much to persons discussed
the Montgomery's plan place.
The main emphasis on the British
contingent and cast the Americans in the
supporting role.
This is what you get fumed pattern
when your commander in chief Eisenhower
ceases to be an American
hands becomes an ally.
The invasion force,
it landed on the beaches of
Sicily on the 10th of July,
1943 by nice for the allies had put
80,000 men and 300 tanks or short.
The next day it patterned himself
came to inspect the beachhead,
wading in the through the surf,
even as artillery shells
exploded around the beach.
While it seemed became clear that the
Germans would not be able to hold Sicily.
They fought a fierce rear guard action
as they began to evacuated their army to
the Italian mainland's.
As Montgomery's army became
bogged down at pattern,
decided to take a loose
interpretation of his orders.
He was expected to support the British,
but I mean surely the best way to do
this would be to hit the Germans heart
pattern.
Dhruv the seventh army on his goal now
was to beat him Montgomery to the city of
[inaudible] in the north of the islands.
He was driven not just
by his personal ambition,
but by a desire to prove that the American
soldier was the best in the world.
The Sicily campaign was
fought at a blistering pace
in blazing heat casualties.
Well,
they were inevitable on August,
1943 paths and visited the
wounded at a field hospital.
When he discovered that
one of the patients was
physically unhurt but suffering
from shell shock,
he exploded with rage pattern.
It slaps to the unfortunate man dragged
in from the tent and kicked him in the
backside and then threatened
to shoot him for cowardice.
Unfortunately,
for pattern,
this extraordinary display had been
conducted under the noses of a number of
journalists patterned and it seemed
to realize had done anything wrong,
but striking.
A subordinate was a court martial offense.
Eisenhower ordered pattern to apologize
bags of the witnesses not to report on
the incidents and hoped that that would
be enough to protect his most dangerous
weapon in the war against the Nazis
spa pattern one is rest in Messina and
through the Nazis out
of Sicily is vicious.
Temper came back to bite him as word.
If his assaults leaked out in the press,
there was this or more
Eisenhower could do pattern.
He was removed from his commands and
with that it seemed as if his Korea,
it might be over
the invasion of Italy,
was a natural result of
the conquest of Sicily.
Patton,
who was ill suited to inactivity B could
only watch on in frustration of even
greater importance than
the campaign and this,
and he was the long awaited
invasion of western Europe.
This would take place in June of
1944 it was one of the most difficult
operations of the war.
There's pattern would have it,
no direct role to play in the invasion.
Instead though there was used as a
decoy given commands of an entirely
fictitious army intended to fool the
Germans into believing that a second
invasion force was preparing
to strike the ruse.
It totally worked.
The Germans never imagines that the
allies would leave their best offensive
general back in Britain.
While such a vote of the offensive
was being fought in France.
Okay,
awesome.
Greatest fear was that the war would
be before he could get back into it.
He needs tons of worried though.
While the success of the initial
allied invasion exceeded expectations,
the British and the Americans made
slow progress as they attempted to push
inland's.
It wasn't until the end of July for the
Americans finally punched the small hole
through the German lines.
Omar Bradley,
commander of the U s grounds forces knew
that this was the moment to get pattern
back into the frame.
Radley it regarded pattern as difficult
to control and predictable and vulgar,
but he recognized his talents pattern
was given commands of the newly formed
Third Army,
a Heidi mobile force equipped with plenty
of art that he was ordered to go back
and it's break through the German
lines pattern that quickly got to work,
squeezed his armored divisions through
the narrowest of gaps in the German
lines,
reform them on the other side and within
a matter of days is Third Army was
tearing through open
country and to Brittany.
The speed of patterns.
Advances often worry to superior.
Since he was a risk taker,
he rarely worried about the
danger of an attack to his flanks.
Hitler himself actually thought it
sniffed out and opportunity to exploit the
allied breakout.
He would launch a counterattack and
cutoff patterns Ahmed's spearheads.
Now this idea,
well,
it did have its merits in theory,
but the German army lacked the strength.
Do you execute the operation in practice?
It was instead the Germans,
he found themselves in danger of being
complete and the encircled at filets pass
and believed he was in a position to
slam the drawers of the trap shot.
Bradley a far more cautious,
commanded them Patton or did the
Third Army to halt our Jensen passing.
He was furious,
but he complied with the order even
though he suspected Bradley had been
influenced by Montgomery.
Yeah,
headless fails.
Counselor attack LEDs to the near collapse
of the German army in France without
a pattern.
It was freeze and launches
blitzkrieg assaults.
His philosophy was relentless attack
and unrelenting pressure that caps the
enemy constantly off balance and to
minimize the Third Army casualties pattern
argued that if he was properly back,
so you've got to cross the river Rhine
and a matter of weeks spots pass and
found himself at once again in
competition with Montgomery,
as each man is empty,
do you secure enough supplies to keep
their army moving as passing complains,
my man can eat their belts,
spares.
My tanks have got to have gas.
Although there were such disagreements
amongst the leading ally generals,
they were United in the belief that
Hitler's armies were all but beaten.
Germany's Phurah.
However,
had one last surprise in
store on the 16th of December,
1944 the Germans launched a vast counter
attack aimed at a thinly held section
of the American lines at our den.
This was the beginning of the battle that
we had become famous as the battle of
the bulge,
the at southern and furious.
The soul's badly rattles,
most allied commodities that's and
recognized once that Hitler had made a
serious strategic error.
Let the sons of bitches
go all the way to Paris.
If they like your job's,
then we can really cut
them off and shoot them up.
Eisenhower to senior commanders do an
emergency conference where he asked how
long it would take a pattern.
Do you divert his third
army to the Adana pattern?
Told him he could have three
divisions there within 48 hours.
This seemingly fantastical claim was
matched with a mixture of laughter.
Then disbelieving stairs,
but pattern.
He was in tiny,
serious hit anticipated Eisenhower's
request and just staff were already making
preparations.
Do you disengage the part of the third
army in order to wheel it around,
they would then race to the
rescue along narrow icy roads.
The Battle of the bulge gave
of the allied high commands,
a shock lets as pattern had predicted
is accomplished nothing and cost.
Hitler has lost reserves now.
The River Rhine was the last significant
obstacles that the western allies have
to tackle.
The main crossing was
to be launched Irvine,
Montgomery.
Mattie spent two months planning
every last detail of the operation,
which calls for an airborne assault,
a huge artillery bombardments and even
the assistance of specialized the US navy
vessels.
Well Gum Murray's crossing was launched
on the 23rd of March by which time
pattern had already stolen his thumbs up,
like quietly sneaking a division
across under the cover of darkness and
establishing a bridgehead
on the other side.
He phones Bradley to let him know
what he'd done but don't tell anyone.
He said because the crowds
haven't realized yet
with its feeds of Germany and tried and
failed to secure a posting to the Far
East in order to play a part
in the war against Japan.
Instead,
he was appointed as
governor of the Varian,
the political posts.
Twitchy was not well suited.
He fell out with the Russians,
refused to remove Nazi personnel from
key administrative positions on the basis
that there was nobody else
qualified to do the job,
and it's got to tricks by a reporter
into agreeing that Nazis joins the party
and more or less the same way as
Americans became Democrats or Republicans
patterns,
political abilities didn't really
compare to his military abilities.
Angie,
once again succeeded
in outraging the press.
His subsequent apology
was deemed insufficient.
Tends.
He was removed from his
post for the second time,
but at this point,
although he didn't know it,
he had only a few months left to live
on December the ninth 1945 pattern was
being driven towards a hunting expedition
when the vehicle he was traveling in
was struck by a truck traveling
in the opposite direction.
Nobody else was hurt.
That's passing,
was paralyzed from the neck
down the injured general.
He was rushed to hospital
where he died 11 days later,
he was buried in Europe alongside the
fallen soldiers who was beloved Third Army
Patton.
It always wanted to die in battle,
but instead he lost his life as the
result of a low speed collision in
peacetime.
Now,
most everybody accepts the official
version of patterns demise and it has been
suggested the person may have
been assassinated by the Russians,
possibly even in collusion
with the u s government.
This would have been as a result of his
outspoken opposition to the Soviet Union
when he died,
he was 60 years old,
so I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos twice a week.
Also,
if you like this video,
check out some of our other videos which
were linking to over there on the right
and as always,
thank you for watching.